this week we are partnered with hellofresh and
Rocket money more on them after the [Music]
reaction what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation I am joined with Aaron Alexander we
are going to watch a movie that I've been wanting
to watch for a long time and I perked up when I
saw Aaron hadn't seen this either hidden figures
Aaron how are you I am doing so good so great I'm
ready for this movie starring terrari starring
to Rari starring to rajie P Henson if this guy
thinks I'm cutting that out and editing it to make
it look smooth he's got another thing coming hey
baby we on the Fly we do it we we flub up words
that's okay we make it up leave a like on this
video people subscribe and click the notification
Bell and while you're at it tell us did you like
hidden figures is this a Hidden Gem in your mind
thank you to preer for helping us edit down these
highlights full length Reaction watch along so
you sync up with your own copy of hidden figures
available first super sexy rejects over at our
patreon page we cover several things over there
exclusively with highlights and watch alongs
included all right Aon you ready to discover
what's been hidden the figures yeah I'm ready for
all the figures yep yeah yeah baby it's going to
be us we're going to ruin the movie for you guys
Janelle Monet octavus Spencer damn Kevin cner
yeah 21 West Virginia Collegiate Institute is
the best school for Negroes in the state really
that's right the only School past the eighth grade
anywhere near here scalene equilateral she's smart
rhombus trapezoid oh they want to take her early
tetrahedron she's like good at geometry naturally
is that what geometry is okay math shapes that's
all I know why don't you solve the equation on
the the board she sees things differently than
the rest of us she's an [Music] X-Men but women
in the 1920s can't do math so if you move all the
terms over to one side you can put the quadratics
into a form that can be factored allowing that
side of the equation to equal zero once you done
that it's St straight forward from there let's go
Little Nerd let go what the hell I've never seen a
mind like the one your daughter has hurry on now
love you have to go she trying to make the rest
of us look stupid you have to see what she becomes
Oprah she becomes [Laughter] [Music] Oprah oh wow
40 years later damn okay try to turn it open now
there a little jiggle wiggle wiggle wiggle that
is definitely the star starter is starting to
make us late we all going to end up unemployed
riding around in this Palace a junk to work every
day you're welcome to walk the 16 miles or sit in
the back of the bus I won't do NE a hitch High
you know from the little bit I know about this
movie this is a really smart opening scene for
the characters for what they're them fixing this
mechanical piece of Machinery together okay
no crime in a broken down car no crime being
negro button it up Mary nobody wants to go to
jail behind your mouth I do my best shoo ladies
are you black you have identification on yes
sir we're just on our way to work NASA sir we
do a great deal of the calculating getting our
rockets in space all three that's crazy NASA I
had no idea they hired colorss you girls ever
meet those astronauts Mercury 7 absolutely we
work with those gentlemen all the time they don't
do they a never even seen an astronaut we got to
get a man up here for the commies do that's was
certain h of service broken down on the side of
the road this cop's taking a l of them what y'all
need a toe or something all you respected man they
smart up the Negroes okay by pass the starter
yeah see NASA imagine you running late to work
oh no so we wouldn't want to bother you that would
be wonderful officer follow me I'm driving hurry
up door these are three great actresses they're
awesome they're all three amazing actors I don't
even know where to begin oh I tell you where to
begin three negro women are chasing a white police
officer that's right that's right that
there is a God orain Miracle oh what I
wish she was able to take a selfie you just
know this is the kind of movie that's going
to have the most excellent props and
costume design and look at the colors
popping already Kevin cner pocket he's
going to be the only one in the thumbnail
second man we really got to beat them goddamn
Russians we're about five minutes in it's
already better than Apollo 18 it's called
Apollo 13 by the way I rest my case yes Mr
President it looks like they've achieved at
least one orbit maybe two when he answered the
call of the President Kennedy was on the back
we're about five minutes in it's already better
than Apollo 18 it's called Apollo 13 by the
way go again so is our comrade Ian a dummy what
the hell proven life can be oh it's it's him I'm
Dr Sheldon Cooper OMG a damn dog and a damn
mannequin 1.6 Megaton RDS drops down in the
middle of De Mo well that's a pretty big jump Paul
Stafford our lead engineer Mr web I think what
he meant to say is that speculation at least on
our side of the equation just a little dangerous
well said damn inaction and indecision Russians
indecision is a thief of opportunity just so you
know he's not wrong about what he said in there
you know that right wow cool framing yeah where's
the machine in a day now Mr Harrison what's it
called the initials the IBM it's lot this cool
like wide Center framing they're doing with
almost every angle I need a mathematician W
andest ah each one of them in their own box
that's cool I like that Christ we don't have
a single person in this entire building that can
handle analytic geometry well tell me something
else we like we're going to find such a person
before the Russians plant a flag on the damn Moon
Russians we're Russian to beat the Russians we
know just the ladies to do it I have no idea who
these women are Mr zalinsky is requesting you
for a permanent assignment are you serious get
moving o thank you Jesus oh thank you Mary keep
it inside Mary Jesus is right there be quiet Mrs
Mitchell is that Kirsten dun kirston dun is
in this what the hell space test group needs
a computer ASAP Computer someone with a handle on
analytic geometry we can't fill that position out
of the East group you have someone I don't need
to talk to him Catherine's a g off of that she
can handle any numbers you put in front of her
I'll check her credentials she was destined for
great things and she's just here a typewriter
and I can't figure out why my application for
supervisor man was just wondering if they're
still considering me for that position well
the official word is no they're not assigning
a permanent supervisor for the Color Group may
I ask why I didn't ask why jeez we haven't had one
since Miss Janson got sick it's been almost a year
things are working just fine as it I'm doing the
work of a super B pay her just fast with rocket
ship slow with advancement get those trajectory
CS worked out need it for the Redstone test fast
food rocket ships set low with advancement what
a crazy irony damn so sad even in the field of
science there's still relegated to second class
of course yeah man science Community bunch of
pompous [Laughter] dicks go in there turn on the
engine uh get out of there what if they just kill
off Janelle mon right now oh my god oh [__] what
if they just kill off Janelle Monae right now oh
come on get it one one moment forget it forget the
hill just run just get out of there 9 8 7 y'all
ain't going to stop it for bro I don't think it's
that simple I I don't think you just turn it off
no one's going to go and help her like why why
would they risk their own lives for someone who
wants to save a shoe CU because of human decency I
guess what do I know that's a great shot we alter
the exterior from smooth to corrugated the capsule
might have most stability Shield erosion occurs on
the posterior side about in the Retro booster
the area closest to the boosters is closest
to the heat couples with Rising temperature on
re-entry yes consider another fascin other than
the boat we should yes I'm I'm keeping up when
I keep up with movies like this it makes me feel
smart I know just as much as they do it's almost
as if I went to school for this a person with
Engineers mind should be an engineer you can't be
a computer the rest of your life I'm a negro woman
I'm not going to entertain the impossible let me
ask ask you if you were a wide M would you wish
to be an engineer I wouldn't have to I'd already
be one be one yeah skirts must be worn past the
knee oh this is going to be a moving ass film
I can feel it Aaron do not talk to Mr Harrison
unless he talks to you things move fast around
here your clearance they've never had a color
in here before Catherine don't embarrass me GH
kick some rocks lady so weird you see so many
movies about racism you hear about all the time
but it never just becomes like depending on who
you are it's not like an easy watch you know yeah
this wasn't empty last night I oh screw you bro
C sometimes I just can't tell if they treat her
this way because she's black or because she's
a woman or is it both I think it's a combo
sandwich double threat double threat double
underestimated Mr Harrison won't warm up to you
don't expect it do you work keep your head down
thank you oh Mr Harrison's going to love her
go on get settled so did these three do like
something incredible and their stories just
been pushed down as history has unfolded as
I have no idea who we're watching yeah me
neither should and did we make it to the
moon they got us there actually what's the
status on that computer she's right behind
you Mr Harrison she is the computer does she
handle analytic geometry absolutely and she's
be you think you can find me the F frame for this
data using the Graham or analization algorithm
yes sir I prefer it over ukian coordinates oh
that's so hot good then I'm going to need it
by the end of the day God I love intellect I'm
also going to ask you to check Mr Stafford's
math as well as others on this floor from time
to time I can handle that out I'm sure you can
Paul shingles wouldn't be flying off the heat
shield now would they he really picks on that
guy in 14 days the Mercury 7 will be here
for training and I have no doubt in my mind
that they're going to be asking us questions
about our work Mercury 7 on top of a missile
shooting into space and it's never been done
before done everything we do between now and
then it's going to matter I believe it's going
to matter to the whole damn country it's pretty
incredible when you think about it man yeah
the achievements yeah how far we've come as
a species amazing less than a hundred years ago
if you tell people who went to the moon I think
you're out of your mind my numbers are spot on
I will double check them sir no problem what an
uphill battle one must climb I'm not going to
be able work on what you can read the rest is
classified you don't have clearance I mean that
might just be at the level she's at it might
not have to do still the undertones are there
are they I think you're reading too much into
it excuse me might ask what the L's room is
sorry I have no idea what your bathroom is
oh my God hate this she might just mean
the woman's bathroom Aon [Laughter] she
oh yeah the pressure women's bathrooms
with the maintenance that's outdated
by 15 years she really need to go to the
bathroom or she like need to cry or maybe
both I think she really just needs to go to
the bathroom yeah she's doing that the the peee
dance the this is so sad the piss breaths they're
underground too but I get whenever I have to poop
in a stranger's house do the same thing you drive
home drive home call an Uber whatever it takes oh
she probably get more done on the crapper than
anyone else H might yeah Ruth where's that girl
with the number on a break we'll take breaks now
so messed up just has do that every time she has
to go to the bathroom go all the way across
the facility I solved it I know how to get to
space Where Have You Been are you finished yet
almost he say by the end of the day the end of
the day around here was yesterday I need those
done first he wants those done first oh God
and she has to be so submissive I don't think
she heard you it's like hard to develop agency
here yeah 60s being a woman being a black woman
being a black woman in science I love how she's
just so in her zone now like she's so comfortable
that she's just in another workplace not even
noticing the people around her she's actively
ignoring it because she has to I think she's
just really in the zone she's in her comfort
zone yeah she freak for a second see well she
cares about them numbers she's smarter than
all of you you dumb pencil pushing dummy just
crackers hey man work late like this prove
yourself yeah un like Aaron wants to get out
of here right [Laughter] away yeah I just said you
know and Stafford he show CS you're the best one
you're better than all of them you know what we're
doing here trying to put put a man into space sir
that's right so you can throw that in the trash
why it's not an insult to your work it's just
obsolete that's how fast things are moving around
here I said I was sorry I'd be saying it all day
that's what I tell my wife what I'm asking you to
do what I'm asking everyone in that room all my
Geniuses is to look beyond the numbers to look
around them that's what she does her answers
the questions we don't even know to ask math it
doesn't yet exist an interesting way to look at
it develop a new mathematical system I don't need
another smart girl with an adding machine can I
go sir yes you can go he's the only non-racist
one in the yep I wonder if that's historically
accurate I hope so I mean Kevin cner I think he
he'd object against playing the racist I want
no racist lines every is racist but me I'm I
am the white Sav I am good I Haven been late
one day in 10 years haven't been out sick my
works on time it's done right it's done well
it's not fair that's a fact you deserve to be
a supervisor it's having the responsibility of
a supervisor but not the title of the pay be told
darthy I don't even know if I can keep up in that
room why I'll be back with the computers in the
week or out of a job entirely oh please the real
struggles is they have to overcome what's with
an in just make that pencil move as fast as your
mind does you'll be fine trust your intuition I
sound like a supervisor don't I a meano saled one
ridd with authority no question these three have
really great chemistry yeah I hope they got along
in real life I'd hope so new assignment space
task group might be a slight promotion but you
want the job right it's a challenge but it's
nothing you can't handle Catherine thank you
Mama oh fascinating she's got it all up here
but there's a lack of faith in here yeah I a
supporter for mom is too we just wanted to say
good night you've been gone for 300 100 hours
I know I work a full-time job now you all know
that I have to be mommy and daddy damn I miss
your father just as much as anyone oh he died
it's going to be one of those movies you could
fly up to space if you wanted to Mama did you draw
this is that me I love you baby oh she even got a
rocket behind her too older daughter all right
now this time really go to bed a wonder if she
pursues the same career paths as her mom growing
up got artists in the family you got others who
seem just as intellectual as her that be really
hard being a mother of three and working at Nasa
oh man his faith in us has no limit the good
Lord has our very own women or can own rocket
ships and this what give a shout of praise
for Colonel Jim Johnson returning home by
the grace of God set up see [__]
new Daddy I don't care that Daddy's
dead you're probably upgrading I
don't I don't understand all this
Hodge too all this hod is in this that's
crazy damn it's like the black Avengers
a NASA's never ever giving you g you do having
a couple extra degrees ain't going to change
that civil rights ain't always s ain't that the
truth just a harsh inner belief system I he he's
don't see any there well that's good for him
go find your way over there that Colonel Jim
is a tall glass of water strong commanded
oh and I bet he's like that day and night
Mary Sund please it's Sunday it's time for
an act of sin is what I say Praise Him in
the sheets he's coming over oh maraw Ali must
have the hidden figure you know what I'm saying
are you singing as a big yeah yeah singing
subtle for YouTube purposes jeez she's not
married she's a widow with three beautiful
little girls so well behaved angels on Earth
is what we like to call why you really son
the daughter Point here I love single mothers
really edifying that Pastor mentioned you
a computer at Nasa we calculate mathematics
necessary to enable launch and Landing
for the space program that is really well
easy to understand pretty heavy stuff they let
women handle that sort of uhoh not the sexism
that's not what I mean it's exactly what I
mean just surprised something so taxing Mr
Johnson I mean no disrespect I mean no
disrespect let me top it off with the
third sexist statement you you can just
put that foot back on put that shoe back
in your foot I analyze the monometer levels
for air displacement friction and velocity
and compute over 10,000 calculations by cosine
square root and lately analytic geometry tell
him his balls just fell off and we're proud to
be doing our part for the country so yes they
let women do some things at Nasa Mr Johnson
and it's not because we wear skirts it's
because we wear glasses hit so fine I mean
I don't know why why that came out of me I'm
sorry handsome must be a requirement too how
could you possibly be hling these white men
I always equal rights I have the right to
see fine in every color that's John Glenn
oh my God the cast just gets better what do you
ladies do for NASA calculate your trajectories
launch and Landing you can't get anywhere
without the numbers no sir Mary Jackson Mr
Glenn engineering and I'm proud of the devil
to be working I love the initiative she takes
yeah you got to be [__] me they just had to
have so much patience back then they didn't
even fill it yall are the worst civil rights may
not be so civil Mr Harrison want you to confirm
launch and Landing for the Redstone Rocket test
wow I cannot work on what I cannot see Mr staff
those numbers have already been confirmed
by two engineers in this department and
myself this is more or less a dummy check
wow wow underscore that word [Applause]
enough off the first page the first
thing you read she's that good you
got that far what are you she can read the hidden
figures I love the music they choose almost goes
it a bit of a film Noir touch yeah singing Jazzy
who directed this I really like the way the
movie is framed our runner can pick up your
work Dorothy you need to be working not walking
oh it's it's great time you need something else
I was wondering if you know what they're
building over in the tech Wing it's called
an IBM a main frame machine apparently it can do
our calculations in a fraction of the time replace
them is everyone just watching
her she got it off the first page
they're watching her like a hawk
they think she's doing graffiti
Greg what are those symbols and like what are the
gang signs you're writing up there woman [Music]
huh my
God she wrote on the white people's [Music]
[Laughter] chalkboard who work is that it's
good I love it Catherine goal sir oh man they're
going to set you up with like a porta potty right
next to your desk now classified information
it's top secret well it's no secret why the
Redstone test keep failing it's fine for
suborbital flight but it can't handle the
weight of the capsule and push it into space
God I don't know what you're saying half this
movie but it is so cool it makes you so fine
you figured all that out with this well what's
there tells the story if you read between the
lines distance from launch to orbit we know
Redstone Mass we know Mercury capsule weight
and the speeds of you did the math yes sir
IBM couldn't do it no no IBM could not do it and
how do you know about the atlas rocket that Dad
is not here like he said it's classified
I held it up to the light well there it
is oh yeah are you a spy Catherine am I what
I said are you a Russian spy I'm not Russian
she's not russing just just to confirm she's a
white lady you can trust her this interrogation
is over figures out something amazing and the
first thing she become suspect it's how it goes
sadly I mean it's really an ultimate tense
time for everyone here you know and then to
be a black woman involved in the middle
of a very tense place like this with so
much at stake yeah the middle of achieving major
historical feat yes that's what I'm talking about
ER NASA doesn't commission females for the
engineer training program that position is
available to any qualified act right except
you don't have the educational requirements
I have a bachelor's degree in mathematics and
physical science is the same as most Engineers
that's right damn you're genius we have a chance
to get ahead they move a Finish Line I just follow
the rules around here and I expect everyone
who works for me to follow them as well and I
love the rules y all should be thankful you have
jobs at all what was that saying y'all should be
thankful you have jobs at all no like the like a
weird edit or weird cut no that was the streamer
oh oops we didn't call attention to it oh that
was a weird editing Choice won't any trouble in
here oh I'm not here for any trouble man what
are you here for to mind my own damn business
a book you have books in the color section
prevent them from literature why I'm so mad
you took that book mom son I pay tax and taxes
pay for everything in that Library can't take
something already a paper that's why I steal
from the library for Tran is a new and exciting
language used by programmers to communicate with
computer it is exciting as it is the wave of the
future this book is not as interesting as
I hoped it would be I thought I grabbed a
fantasy [Applause] it's just crazy that like
this is a PG version of it you know and it
wasn't that long like there's still there's
still so many horrible places to be right now
and racism still so real but like this being
the norm everywhere not that long ago there's
still Sundown towns which is [Music] insane
come on you know you want to great I simply
misspoke the other day Mrs go I've been away for
a long time and imagine I'm just out of practice
I went to a woman's rights class I attended
the first seminar Tau by a woman barely paid
attention you haven't said you're sorry Yet
right of course look at this weird swaying
happening they're just like barely move I'm
sorry C underestimating you and any other
woman like you though I don't imagine there's
many M that's a really good way to finish that
line off I've changed my perspective is
enhanced but you are still very unique
in my eyes oh so so well done Yuri Garin
has become the first man in space Gagarin
completed one full orbit around the damn it
Cosa Yori gagarin's 3ka capsule into orbit
re-entering Russian airspace at 755 UTC you
know racism whatever this is what made America
embarrassing imagine being the first man in space
be horrifying oh my God no
one's ever been this high
before I've been asking myself all the way over
here which is how in the hell do we find oursel
in second place in a two-man race why do we suck
I refuse to believe that the Russians are smarter
than us or that they have more technology or
that they care more is it possible that it
actually means more to them we're in the fight
of Our Lives people I just saw seven faces who
aren't sure that we can get there wow there's
only two things you need to know going forward
one is staying here working late that's going
to be a fact of life and two don't expect your
paychecks to reflect the extra time it's going
to take to catch up and pass those bastards what
a bold statement I suggest you call your wives on
how it's going to be I'll start with mine working
late does anyone quit who will quit
from this I just want to be a part
of it there too much pressure I got
to go I I want to be a part of it man
I wouldn't want to be a part of such a
historical moment trying to make history
[Music]
here fascinating simulation process end of the day
damn oh aggressive there hey we
we're looking good where to go
IBM you don't want to leave that behind
which one of you want wants to go
first he's always playing people that like to
fly this is like his third movie this is typ
C the guy who gets in a in a in a aerial [Music]
vehical some sort of craft yeah Top Gun that one
with Jonathan Maes and this one the computer uses
it as its high-speed storage unit and information
holding device you have a brain that I can work
with oh that's from the wrong spot I really like
the way they're they're written like our three
three female leads like there's nothing about
it that sounds like preachy at all about them
they are like they have real personality and
they they're also really intelligent you know yeah
I know it feels it feels very authentic where is
she she is always leaving Having
Fun get this girl a bathroom man she should have
she she should have addressed it she should oh
her hair got all messed up too damn where
the hell have you been now where the hell
do you go every day a to the bathroom sir for
40 minutes a day what are you doing now we're
T minus Z here I put a lot of faith in you oh
jeez there's no bathroom for me here what do
you mean there's no bathroom for you here there
is no bathroom there are no colored bathrooms
in this building or any building outside the
west camp a I have half a mile Buck to just
to relieve myself and I can't use one of the
handy bikes picture that Mr Harrison oh you
feel embarrassed now don't you lady skirt below
my knees my heels and a simple String of Pearls
well I don't own pearls Lord knows you don't pay
colors enough to afford pearls Jesus and I work
like a dog living off a coffee from a pot none
of you want to touch wow excuse me if I have to
go to the restroom a few times a day makes feel
pretty embarrassed now man and she's treated like
garbage he defeated racism
no now she can't have any
coffee oh my God he's doing it he's
wh saving us that's what I'm talking
about I mean in this you kind of need a whs
saer in this position you know yeah [Music]
there you have it not going to listen to No
More white restrooms just plain old toilets
go wherever you damn will please God damn
preferably closer your desk men and women
share the same bathrooms now something tell me
that didn't actually happen that's the only thing
I believe that [Laughter] happened he's like all
right women are equal women are equal women are
equal equal and blacks woman and blacks heard
you was fighting the fluig you could use some
soup hot meal for the girls okay ladies let's
say gr uhoh she getting sick sick o might as
well be married now it's a historic day here at
Cape canaval and here's what we can expect Alan
Shepard and freedom 7 will be launched into
space at an altitude of about 116 mph what's
taking them so long to get to space man Russians
did it a while ago God you lazy Americans get it
together Freedom we're going to have to bleed
off some of the pressure inside the liquid
oxygen tank that should some D I was like CGI
that's good [Laughter] CG we have ignition and
we have Li it's cool they're inter spcy with real
footage yeah come on I don't know if that's real
footage sure looks real minutes after the
hour definitely real yeah they really got
that shot Y is okay Switching manual R woo
we did it we're catching up the eyes of the
world now look into space to the moon and to
the planets Beyond and we have vowed that we
shall not see it governed by a hostile oh
no but by a b it's a lot harder it inter
splices than it looks wow because there is new
knowledge totally real real footage suppose we
should all thank President Kennedy for the
continued job security that's right uh Gus
gom's up next another suborbital flight with
a redstone I sucker for snaps before we strap
Glenn to the atlas pray we can bring him
back down yes and I imagine he'd like us
to have the math worked out beforehand work
gentlemen wow she's the only one in color in
that whole room oh she must feel special the
colored girl in color little spoton [Laughter]
movie you know what I like about this H you
know how normally like a movie will have like
the relegated female love interest that's
what Mersa Ali is he's the love interest
he is the lest look at him I think it's
high time I kissed you C figured you
attracted to me same as out of you he's
got the greatest voice I swear when You'
have told me to get going a long time
ago man is smooth I'm going to kiss you
now haven't kissed a man in a long
time almost forgot how to a let me
remind you yeah you want do it
again damn you still got the flu
baby arrested four white men accused of throwing
a fire bomb into a freedom rider bus that is a
tragic event it is a struggle to save the soul
of America Mary it's just crazy they I like that
they're putting the backdrop of what's going on
in the in in America when it comes to black people
meanwhile you got these black women who are doing
incredible things that sh help shape a big part of
our history yeah it's really and they been yeah
undervalued even in today's standards cuz most
people don't know about them Hampton High School
is a white School Mrs Jackson yes your honor I'm
aware of that what would warrant a colored woman
attending a white school May I approach your binge
sir cff you of all people should understand
understand The Importance of Being first how's
that Mrs Jackson well you were the first in
your family to serve in the armed forces US
Navy damn I bet most people don't know this and
the first state judge to be recommissioned by
three consecutive Governors she did her research
no negro woman in the state of Virginia has ever
attended an all white high school and before
Alan Shepard sat on top of a rocket no other
American had ever touch space and now he will
forever be remembered as the US Navy man from
New Hampshire the first first to touch the St
I mainly think about Neil Armstrong I plan on
being an engineer at Nasa but I can't do
that without taking them classes at that
allwhite high school and I can't change the
color of my skin so I have no choice but to
be the first which I can't do without you sir
hell yeah that's break that that's cool out of
all the cases you going to hear today which one
is going to matter 100 years from now which one
is going to make you the first you trying to
make history or what only the night classes
jez
oh damn oh [__] she slapped her name on there
mhm I'd like to get a jump on John Glenn's
trajectory do you have any idea what you're asking
an orbital launch with an atlas rocket is going
to take time is there a problem I was wondering
uhhuh well I've been wondering my whole life so
you just spit it out I would like to get a jump on
John Glenn's trajectory it's like shooting a saw
off shotgun from 1,000 ft and getting that one BB
through a hole so tiny you can't even see it I'm
an excellent shot how grome numbers been they've
been spot on give Glenn's orbit ago why does
everyone everyone just doubts her every time but
she keeps proving them wrong how many times you
got to prove herself before you trust this woman
damn computers don't author reports guyy such a
prick I bet he's a Russian spy loud and clear okay
it's a nice ride up to now Roger Liberty L 7 this
is H approaching ready to hook on over I read you
loud and clear over space was cool at first but
it's kind of boring out there there nothing
to do out there lack of stimulation I got to
say floating gets old after a while unfortunately
the Liberty Bell 7 capsule is lost no gravity's a
little underrated overrated capsu was lost yeah
you shouldn't have made any jokes Aaron very
insensitive we have to know what's out there
Senator we have to touch the Stars if only
to ensure our own Survival and only a man can do
that we'll get John Glenn home safely because we
have to because he has to tell us what he saw
and that's the only reason Atlas rocket goes
up delivers the capsule into an elliptical orbit
Earth's gravity keeps pulling at it but is going
so fast it keeps missing the Earth getting it back
down that's the math we don't know I figure it out
so the capsule will spin around the Earth forever
because there's nothing to slow it down slowing it
down at precisely the right moment by precisely
the right amount that's the task yes Katherine
to move from an elliptical orbit to parabolic
no this point it's a pin head we bring him in
too soon he burns up on re-entry we bring him in
too late he's pushed out of Earth's gravity and
any changes to mass weight speed time and we start
our calculations this would be very precise yeah
thought it was easy get over there he's just
get a giant magnet Pentagon briefing should
illuminate where the Navy needs the recovery zone
then we work backwards from there and the rest is
on us so let's get to work I just love how it's
like a mission priority it's not some hey would
be great to figure out how to get to space
like this is life or death leave it's space
everything's right this well we can't keep up I
need those changes as they occur as you said it's
a pin Catherine that's the job when you asked for
this assignment so just calculate with what you
have or we'll find someone who can oh my God you
will not be able to you guys just value this woman
please that a girl hey what the hell are
you doing you can't be in here she fixed
the machine Dorothy B sir well this is a very
delicate piece of equipment I'm sorry sir I'm
just trying to be helpful she fixed it
we've got numbers what kind of numbers
she just wants to be a supervisor she deserves
it what's your name again Dorth Von Dorth Von
she keeps the job they need someone like
her keep that job get that raise oh this
is all mood we're altering the window on the
capsule when did this happen 6 minutes ago
the math is changing start over if I could
attend the briefings I could stay we have
been through this it is not possible there is no
protocol for is there a problem look Catherine in
the come on CER use white safe Costner there's
a big cost to not letting her in there your cost
her [Laughter] opportunity keep slapping your
goddamn name on her Mr Harrison I would like
to attend today's briefing why is that well sir
the data changes so fast the capsule changes the
weight and the landing zones are all changing
every day she needs to be in there Coronel
Glenn launches in a few weeks we don't have
the man figured out yet why is it she can't
attend cuz she doesn't have clearance Al I
cannot do my work effectively it's cuz she's
a negro owl Pentagon briefings are not for
civilians it requires the highest clearance
I feel like I'm the best person to present my
calculations no I am not and she is a woman
there is no protocol for a woman I get that
part Paul I'm a good man Kevin CER plays good
people who makes the rules you sir you are
the boss you just have to act like one sir
man this guy I feel like this guy's going to S
is he like the villain of the movie this's going
to sabotage everything he also has a hidden
figure it's cuz it's really tiny can't even
that's clever find it her work is pertinent to
today's proceedings come on rator so awkward
with all due respect our capsules being altered
daily we're orbiting the Earth at what speed
now she can answer 17544 mph that's what
I'm talking about at the time the rocket
delivers the capsule into low space orbit
there it is so we have the vehicle speed
the launch window and for arguments sake The
Landing zone is the Bahamas should be enough
to figure the go no go yeah in theory
sir we need to be past Theory at this
point we'll be able to it's just a theory a
space Theory a space Theory Catherine have
a go at it do your thing Catherine do your
thing Catherine I allow you use the white
chock now if I was one of these B
background players I'd be overdoing it be
like black woman in the room if we assume that's
the Bahamas at 17,5 44 milph entry yeah yeah screw
you IBM of 4656 I think IBM's actually been
very helpful for us I should take this they
still use it do you know do they I don't know
chat gbt now 32t distance would be 20 million
look got to go to work man I wonder what her
preparation process was for this movie that's
a good question mil he's like I've never seen
her actually do this this is crazy my first
time this is crazy that's awesome Shin Z at
5 0 66 7° North yep 33° West B you feel like
a real ass now Jim person like get out you
don't have clearance you're a woman that of
course is assuming the capsule hits the re-entry
point exactly how do we ensure that he's still
so shocked by what he just witnessed we're
working on it Catherine gentlemen I'd like
to sleep with her that was the hottest thing
I've ever seen programmers folks to feed the
cars we get them for crying out loud okay you're
the IBM man right yes sir we pull out the sky if
you have to let's get ahead of this thing I'm
not paying you where's that black girl get the
black girl back out here K going to be like are
all the black girls running everything around
here it's like they've had to do all this
the Shadows that are coming to the light
temporarily yes we need the abbm for
Glenn's launch the lead engineer says
you're good with the cards pring they're the
hidden figures is that what the movie's title
was what about after now after Glenn's launch
NASA's dissolving the Computing group really
I'm not accepting re unless I bring my ladies
with there you go there you go we're going to
need a lot of manpower to program that Beast
I can't do it alone oh my God so cool and
they know they need her so no matter they need
her so bad like oh wait to elevate we've been
reassigned oh God I am nothing like her I would
abandon everyone here at this channel for greater
success sorry [Music] ladies holy
[__] this all a true story I I
got to look up what's true what is
that's that is wild that that's so
amazing that is so cool I got to look this
up I got to let's pause the movie right
now look at her math in way saying things
I'll never understand find a genius among
those Geniuses pull us all up we all get to the
peak together or we don't get there at all well
good night Sir you're fired Paul I don't know
what time I'm coming home you got something to
say thought you might need to you can refill
with any weight LED man these two would have
such beautiful children two gorgeous people you're
going to make a fine engineer you think so yes a
and nobody there standing away a Mary Jackson's
dreams a don't make me late you w't be late I'm
make you you w be late it's nice to see a movie
like his men supporting like the men supporting
women and uh supportive black and and and you
got these two male leading actors sure relegated
to the romance you just don't see that that often
I'm Mary Jackson I'm enrolled man maybe you right
this is all high schoolers ER yeah something in
the water back then curriculum is not designed
for teaching a woman well I imagine it's the
same as teaching a man I don't see a colored
section should I just take any seed thank you
that's cool take the [Music] front okay everyone
look schooler is when the capsule moves from an
elliptical orbit to a parabolic orbit there's no
mathematical formula for that calculate launch and
Landing but without this conversion the capsule
stays in orbit we can't bring it back home right
right right I I think I know what you're saying
maybe we've been thinking about this all wrong oh
yeah maybe yeah yeah definitely I'm right there
in the room with you guys that's how I keep my
job uhhuh yeahhuh something that looks at the
problem new Al and not theoretically that's a
good point Oiler method Oiler method yes mutter
mutter that's ancient Ponder Ponder
Ponder Ponder what a radical way of
thinking that's it let's type it up are you
going to let her put her name on it you're
going to give her the credit it's going to
have that moment be like hey it doesn't say
by Catherine yeah see yeah oh he's going to
he's going to have his moment where he says
it do it man do it we need redemption or else
I'm not going to watch big Bank Theory anymore
I hear the IBM's up to full capacity you
certainly have a knack for it my father
taught me a thing or two about mechanics
I have a few girls in the East group that
have an interest in learning more about it
that's not my decision ma'am that would be
the supervisor yes that's true are you going to
offer it to her in the bathroom you know Dorothy
despite what you may think I have nothing
against y'all I know you probably believe
that damn she just knows how to Octavia Fester
knows how to drop lines like that she's so good
you don't know what she going to say but something
clever's about to come out some bar about to drop
some truth truth bombs in here you probably
believe that but wait is it my birthday no mama
you all look so pretty it's Daddy's deathiversary
mama what's going on good evening Catherine what's
happening okay well I'm not going to do this all
night oh Mother of Mercy that's for me oh is he
doing this in front of the whole family no a no
it's okay Mama he's a good man I know what I know
I just I just can't help you hasn't even asked
you yet yo no my mother's ring beautiful she
and my father were married for for 52 years that
girl's good numbers I said Mom I'm at the woman
I want to marry what' she say she said she must
be something Jimmy really something then what'
you say I said no she more than something she's
everything oh hell yeah this guy's good too man
I plan on on this being more romantic I'll make
that up to you real soon this is great what are
you talking about but I know marrying you includes
man and your girls as well that is so sweet I do I
ask you again hurry up a that is so sweet that
can't be truth no no man's the smart to do it
for the whole family like that oh that's great
it's like proposing me like will you accept me
as your St father that's great in fact our IBM
is turning out numbers in fractions of the time
any human can present company included that's
good then they haven't even like been able to
really talk with each other huh the girls no
it's been a minute since we've seen them all
together thing is the cape's now insisting
on doing all the backups down there on side
so we won't be running backups here and truth
be told we can't keep up with that IBM anyhow
long story short we no longer need a computer in
this department wow she got you guys this far and
she going to throw her away like trash we heard
you got engaged yes huh it's thoughtful of you a
Mr Harrison's idea really although I suspect
his wife did the picking up can't imagine he
has an eye for anything but numbers now you have a
great wi did good work around here Catherine white
people approve crazy how there's like a sense
of irony about it you know cuz she helped get
the IBM thing working putting her out of a job
and a little Fuller what you look good here we
go again Octavia advancing herself kind of screwed
over her friend that's what I [Laughter] [Music]
was Paul something's off here these Landing
coordinates don't match yesterday's that's
why you can't trust chat gbt even though it
comes up with everything I say on camera even
that was scripted by Chad gbt I'm just reading
a prompt right now the IBM's been spot on up to
this point we'll run it again see what it comes
up with when I fly I fly the machine right now
seems like this machine's flying me let's get
the girl to check the numbers wow really did
that really happen you mean Catherine yes sir
the smart one I mean if she says they're good
I'm ready to go all right we'll get into it
Roger did that call really happen oh Wonder
yeah go find Catherine goo she needs to verify
Glenn's go no go we're staying on the ground
she had wedding right now did she already get
married she had a wedding and there was a time
Tri or is she I have to imagine for movie purposes
they're going to have it happen at her wedding we
need you like as she's about to say her V we
didn't see the wedding no I feel like this is
happening simultaneously I love how he's having
to do the running too now looking for Catherine
Goble it's Catherine Johnson now they need you
to okay mind I wish would have saw the wedding
that's all gather John Glenn is ready to board the
Friendship s but today we remain truly optimistic
and it's a go day in all regards God I got to
become a billionaire so I can go to space what
would you do in space with your billions take a
dump watch it spin in the air I [Laughter] would
after years of waiting and months of delay
Colonel Glenn is finally ready for that space
flight that's it were the calculations wrong
what the devil are you doing are you taking a
[Music] break they're going to run half a
mile they just shut her out cner bring her in
tear down that that door they had her run all the
way there and then they just shut her out that's
crazy Cosner's going to open it though what they
[Laughter] cner come on come on I'm saving you
come on did that really happen I doubt it what
happened movie I I I would love to see I got
to find out I got to find out we can confirm
the go no go point for re-entry is is in
his contract has like I have to wipe save
a minimum of three times hey man he's doing it
let him do his thing he danced with Wolves now
he saves black people a true American hero the
launch window is a go The Landing coordinates
match that is very good news Al it's a a
little hard to trust some you can't look
in the eyes Catherine did manage to calculate
a few decimal points further than that honk
of metal and we are watching this on Disney plus
right now who would Echo the same sentiment as CH
GL awesome get a little bumpy
along here you are in Max
Q whoa wow John Glen reports everything looks
good you go Glenn how what's his
name Howard John Glen pow Glen
po here we go Glen pal thank you cap pil
it away all 10 and a half hours to go if we
make seven round trips honestly I feel like
you get over space really fast you're bored
all right 10 hours I'm I'm good I don't
think I need to do it again s everything
I need to see new assignment came down the PK
always changing around here it's hard to keep
up what they're going to need a permanent team to
feed that IBM how big of a team 30 to start thank
you for the information Mrs Mitchell you're quite
welcome Mrs B now do you think do you still think
I'm racist do do you like me now have I been
redeemed I like these cheesy overcome races I
really do I think I like them all I don't hate
colors my dog's black the heat shield may have
come loose seven will you confirm the landing
bag is in the off position affirmative Capcom
now she's going to have to do something exclusive
that IBM cannot solve NASA is confirming there
is some sort of malfunction with the capsule's
heat shield and if may not stay in place Jesus
the Retro package straps might might hold it in
place it will hold it until he reaches the go no
go point it will work he has to override the 05g
you should get your engineer in here the Retro
package not I repeat not be jettison me that
you will have to override the 05g switch is
there a reason for this over do we telling the
truth I don't want to freak him out he's not a
professional you can't handle the pressure not
at this time s Roger that command without a heat
shield there is no way that Colonel Glenn can get
back through the Earth's atmosphere I don't know
if I've seen a movie that actually captures
this where you just see like the civilians
all watching and looking up at the sky usually
like cut to people like watching the television
or listening to news but just like oh man
there's a guy up there right now you know
like how weird I wonder if people actually did
this though I oh I bet yeah like actually like
gather like looking up at the sky and [__] when
this was happening yeah man they're all listening
to this is a Monumental moment you're going
out he's crossing the communication blackout
Zone there's a real Fireball outside it's
getting a little hot in here no there's
[Music] not it's getting hot in
here friendship seven do you copy
over again friendship 7 do you copy over boom
that's [__] up friendship 7 do you copy
over let clear Capcom Roger that how are
you doing I feel like my sk's on fire but
I'm good engaging shoots beautiful shoot
your go no go is good Landing coordinates
are spot on S I've always wanted to swim in the
Bahamas over like these scenes are so prevalent
in movies and imagine just like it has the
emotional resolution or something like this
but like something goes horribly wrong at the
end John Glenn has splashed down safely and is
being recovered by the USS Noah hell yeah man
that's what I'm talking about yeah you think we
can get to the mo we're already there sir post
credit scene Catherine will return hat figures
to John Glenn successful committed three of
a scheduled seven orbit flight yeah well done
John it was all you friendship S turn the tight
Space Race play NASA the moon in 1969 that's
what I'm talking about America yeah Mary
Jackson Nas is an America's first female
African-American aeronautical engineer 199 she
was appointed Lang Le woman program manager where
she fought to advance woman of all colors hell
yeah hell yeah supervisor show you how things
kst death is not racist in real [Laughter] life
first African-American supervisor damn as a for
specialist on the front tier of electronic
Computing she was regard as one of the most
Brilliant Minds in NASA oh awesome what a what
a step up that's amazing oh yeah put your name
on that paper put your name on that document
Catherine you earned it a what you getting
her the coffee white Redemption we've come a
long way Catherine was fired shortly thereat
wow we're dark have to perform calculations
for the Apollo to the moon and space shuttle
that's what I'm talking about NASA dedicated the
Katherine G Johnson computational Building honor
for groundbreaking work in space travel that's
awesome man these three women are incredible 9797
the presidential medal of freedom and celebrate
56th anniversary of Jim Johnson awesome amazing
I'm sure everything was just great for her you
know whole journey I'm sure we didn't leave
anything out no more racism after this wow
oh it's not real her wow she looks just like
her cool exactly like [Music] her damn kind
of looks like Tessa Thompson actually I can
see that yeah whoa jackon Jackson look at
them ladies wow ladies that's beautiful
that's awesome hidden figures wow
indeed damn I'd watch a I'd watch
a documentary about them oh yeah
in my own time don't ask us to
react Katherine will return all right I must I
must I mean I want to see the photos but must
prepare for for facts checking must learn if
what's true and what isn't true must download
information on factual accuracy must learn
but did Kevin Cosner actually tear the sign
down did he open that door for
her hey bed on a book or something it's based
on real life damn look at the
people work done oh wow look at
that oh cool wow
a oh wow that's amazing man it would have
been great to meet one of them story I
would have shaken their head and been like
I know exactly what it feels like to be you
I I can I have very similar experience I
completely identify with everything you've
been through everything before and during my
God look it's mersel holy hey man not like a
black man is light-skinned very lightskinned
Glenn Powell it look like an Asian guy are
you sure thought it was an Asian guy Glen
palcon looks like an Asian guy no Le's guy
oh snap Diggity yeah yeah thanks to everyone who
worked on this movie thank you to America's number
one meal kid hellofresh for partnering with us
it's always great to partner with people whose
Services you actually use because it's someone
like me who's always juggling a pack schedule
between filming and editing finding time for
health eating can be a challenge that's where
hellofresh has been a game changer for my life
with hellofresh I get farm fresh pre-portioned
ingredients and delicious recipes delivered
right to my doorstep so I don't have to step
outside it's revolutionized my home cooking
experience making it not just easy but super
enjoyable and affordable keyw I recently tried
their delicious barbecue pineapple flat RADS and
their zucchini pomodora Panet bake both were
mouth wateringly delicious and fit perfectly
with my pescatarian lifestyle pescatarian sounds
fancy and ask my friends who love meat hellofresh
has an incredible variety tempts me to be a meat
eater again people I know I've really recommended
their lemon parsley chicken palard I think is how
you pronounce it in the fuo chicken faito tacos
regardless hellofresh menu has something for
everyone but of course it's not just about the
food it's about saving time too not having a wait
in line at a grocery store even self checkouts on
fast enough these days the convenience of having
everything delivered pre-portion right to your
door is priceless especially with her quick and
easy meals like 15-minute recipes spending less
time in the kitchen and more time doing what
I love which is filming and editing so here's
the deal if you want a great way to support the
channel and also support you know having a new
lifestyle healthy affordable lifestyle in the year
2024 go to hellofresh.com reject free and use code
rejects free for free breakfast for life you heard
that right one breakfast item per box while the
subscription is active free breakfast for life for
hellofresh.com reject free use promo code reject
free try it out and let me know your favorite
dishes stay healthy and let's keep enjoying
those movies and shows all right reject Nation
let's get real for a moment running this channel
is incredible managing finances especially taxes
and budgeting both for the channel and my personal
life can be overwhelming that's where rocket money
has been a financial Lifesaver for me even before
I ever partnered up with them like I said I've
been very fortunate to be working with Brands
whose products I already use so it's a win-win
for a while but it can be a win-win for you too
cuz there's a reason I use them rocket money is
a personal finance app that simplifies managing
money by canceling unnecessary subscriptions
lowering bills and crafting a budget that fits
your specific lifestyle for someone like me who
can easily lose track of expenses throughout every
single day of the month it's been eye openening
to see where I was overspending stuff I don't
use that I kept paying for especially apps man
I was way too many apps rocket money does the
heavy lifting by analyzing your spending then
customizes notifications to help you stay within
your budget goals it's not just about saving
money it's about actively seeing and feeling
your financial progress It's a great feeling they
track your monthly subscriptions too so many free
trials I signed up for that I forgot to you know
get rid of before the free Tri was done making
it super easy to cancel the ones you don't use
couple of clicks and you're putting money back in
your pocket telling you have you ever found hidden
subscriptions or pay for services you forgot about
because rocket money is a huge asset in helping
to uncover those and even negotiate some of my
bills down to like 20% so if you're ready to
take control of your finances and there's no
better time than now because it is the beginning
of the year check out rocket money and see how
much you could be saving stop wasting money on
things you do not use so to help support the
channel and help support your wallet visit rocket
money.com rejects rocket money currently has over
5 million users and has helped save its members
an average of $720 a year with over $500 million
in canceled subscriptions they've helped me and
I'm confident they'll do the same for you that's
rocket money.com rejects your bank account will
thank you all right all film kicks off in 1961
and takes place over the following two years yeah
like a couple years but in reality Mary Jackson
became the first black female engineer in s 58 in
Dorothy vom history of becoming a supervisor more
than a decade early in 1949 oh they need some
drama they still they still made that impact in
history they still made their Mark by earlier
getting these positions graduations the three
women's closeness I was really wondering about
this CU they barely together in the film that
hurts it hurts that they weren't close they barely
well let's find out let's find out all right all
right Mary Katherine Dorothy didn't actually
cross paths as much as in the film they seem
like they were best buds right and they definitely
weren't close friends who attended events for
family Milestones this narrative change put the
woman together a variety of scenarios where they
actually went have worked together frequently
emphasizing their closest in the film let them
Express themselves to other women who are in a
similar situations to themselves but it's also
not really true yeah you see I had just a very
cuz none of their stories really related to each
other cuz I was like what a coincidence that the
three of them would be best friends and and go
to work together and then also make these like
massive achievements and individual spots and
their personal like what a crazy these are the
coolest friends I've ever seen I mean still a
massively impressive what they've done but once I
realize like they're not really sharing that many
scenes together and it's really mainly Catherine
story I started questioning the validity of how
close they were all right police incident uh yeah
that carpool scene's probably made up because they
didn't actually hang out with each other yeah all
right oh okay hold on SEC okay Katherine me told
women aren't allowed in briefings I right okay
uh okay oh that's actually pretty accurate of
how she like got in to the briefings that's
cool that's awesome oh Kevin Ker's character
all right let's see he plays he's not a real guy
Harrison Harrison is not her real movies director
wasn't able to secure the r to portray the real
person who wanted to so create a character who
is a composite of three different NASA directors
oh my God car similarly Jim Parson wasn't real
which is for the best ining his racist and sexist
attitudes find the woman that cir n played Vivien
Mitchell is also a fictional creation holy [__]
our three main whes ain't even real whes wow cuz
the real white people were so bad they couldn't
be on screen C was like I want to be the super
white yeah let them be subtly racist or not so
subtle getting rid of the SEC gated toilet wrong
and one of the most satisfying moments of the
movie Kevin C's character dramatically smashes
the sign for the color lady's bathroom there are
a few problems with the scene one Coster did not
exist second segregation ended at Langley in 1958
oh wow some critics argue that this created an
unnecessary white savior moment hey there's always
room for a white savior moment what else do they
have in a movie like this the movie screenwriter
and director ctor Theodore melie countered that
there needs to be white people who do the right
thing there needs to be black people who do the
right thing and someone does the right thing and
so who cares who does the right thing as long as
the right thing is achieved before we read the
rest the mie are you white or black I must find
out because you know it's a fair point he's a
white guy he's white he did a good job though
look good it's a good it was it was a so like your
movie Man movie it was a good movie great looking
wife Kimberly Quinn awesome I I don't know who you
you people are all right um I like the movie guys
all right Katherine Johnson Computing John Glenn's
trajectory that is correct hell yeah when the
first American doo in the movie we see Katherine
working on Glen chory which is totally accurate is
that uh when IBM computers seem to be giving them
inconsistent numbers Glen Glenn really did ask for
johnon civility to check out the figures for him
and that he was willing to fly that day if she
confirm them because hidden figures is a double
meaning Ern what y he talking about the figures
but also they're the figures in history that have
oh my god get it margar Le sh the author of the
book H and figure she is based on a book dude
okay uh so the Astron became a hero looked to
the black woman in this still segregated South
at the time as one of the key parts of making
sure his mission would be a success is what I'm
talking about that is a real it's not really a
savior moment it's actually the black one who
saved but it makes him look great running half
a mile they used the bathroom Okay dramatic for
dramatic effect uh she had half a mile to another
building in order to use the colored bathroom in
fact Mary Jackson Who encountered the problem Mary
it was Mary Jackson Who encountered this problem
not Johnson both had start Lang before the NAC
okay all right just Swit it around yeah cther
Catherine's experience a workplace racism shocker
um is wrong Katherine takes a stand against the
segregation in NASA the real Katherine has stated
that racism didn't affect her much in the birth
place everyone was really nice they brought her
gifts every day when she spoke to w H TV she
said I didn't feel the segregation NASA because
everyone was there doing research actually is
a shocker sarcasm at first you had a mission
and you worked on it it was important to you to
do your job and play bridge at lunch I didn't
feel any segregation I knew it was there but I
didn't feel it perhaps to reflect prac I mean
you got to have the drama man here's the thing
I feel like cuz after seeing what they actually
look like I'm going to say that like there's a
little colorism at play here she's a very like
fair skinned light-skinned black woman which I
feel like if she was a darker skinned black woman
she would have gotten more harsher treatment you
think so definitely let's look her up Catherine
Langley especially back then yeah what's her
last name ly lingford it wasn't Johnson is it
Johnson she got married came Johnson but what
was she known as no Langley is the place of is
yeah I think you're right God damn it you might be
right Katherine Johnson yeah it's easy to remember
not bad two and a half hours in PID for we got s
more minutes we're right here we need a look at
the colored photo we need a colored photo of the
black woman that's not her is that her yeah it's
her she's like she's like white passing I mean as
a super old lady maybe she got that way as she got
older I don't know maybe wife why are all the
younger photos in black and white what's up
with that I can't I don't know man I mean she
at some photos she she looks like definitely
black where I'm not saying she doesn't look
black I'm just saying because she's lighter
skinned that colorism is at play cuz they're like
you look closer to us in tone okay we can be was
easier to accept but yeah she was like like Daniel
kala black they'd be like oh I don't trust these
colored yeah that's fair I don't know I mean no
I do know plays it plays oh yeah that's fair uh
segregation is very real in the street uhuh uhuh
okay all right wow well you kind of pick up on it
as the movie goes that some of this is a little
Hokey Pokey that's why it feels very Hollywood
that's why I just started making jokes because I
was like you can just tell that some of this just
is like you know that has that like H but I can't
lie to you guys I enjoy it I enjoy that kind of
[__] for some reason even when I'm watching
it going like come on or yeah a white savior
movie I I love them I eat them up I eat your
white savior I I really do enjoy them and um
I think there's just enough actual really good
things in here that really work for me I think
it's a touching story it still effectively gets
the point across um the like the the important
part about and like the the important part about
it that I think they got right is uh the mark that
they were able to make and like they really did
become in they really did come into the positions
that they came into as the first African-American
women to do so you know and a lot of especially
for someone like Katherine Johnson did some very
extremely pivotal important stuff and and I think
con conveying that is important even if you have
to like do some narrative bullshitting to get it
done you know I still think they got that point
across and uh it it got me curious to like want
to look up with I was like I just got to know I
got to find out so you learn a little bit more
about the truth behind it and it's a story that
I won't ult I will ultimately never forget and
I my immediate reaction was like oh I'd love
to see like a documentary about them uh like
to really learn the truth so I think for those
purposes alone it's good it's it's a touching
story it's another story about you know like
don't be racist because you never know like
they might be you might be able to get some good
gains from them right it's the lesson that be
learned yeah don't be racist don't be a freaking
prick don't be RAC you might be able to you might
be able to benefit off of their knowledge and
labor and their labor great choice of wordss
same oh God I hey man look I'm
not despite what you think I
have nothing against any people
my dog's black I vote for my dog
twice that's funny that's my dog right
there oh man okay I mean I also liked the movie
I will say that part of me is like I I felt the
Holiness of the movie too and it it does sadden
me a little bit seeing some of these stuff some
of the things that we looked up are uh actually
inaccurate but you kind of sense that as you're
watching as well well let me ask let let
me put it to you like this then before we
looked up this stuff yeah because I can easily
look at this stuff but still know exactly how
I feel about the movie um does any of before
we looked it up what was your feelings before
we looked it up I thought that 10 out of 10
Masterpiece best black movie of the year no
I think before I looked it up or we looked it
up I thought it was entertaining I think that
you know I like the parallels between what the
black experience was at the time versus what
they were experiencing within their workplace
it wasn't to the severity of what they knew on
the outside but still it was present and I
just think that watching it uh yeah made me
really grateful and it showed the strength of
what it was like to be not only black not only
a woman but both of those things within that
workplace and God knows being black and a woman
is hard in America so being black and a woman
in the 60s was even tougher and the amount of
West Virginia my God and West Virginia yeah and
the strength you got to have on top of being a
mother so you got to like feed your kids and go
to work and deal with the workplace drama of it
and I think the the part that like really hit me
was the fact that you know before we look this
up the the fictionalized version of Katherine
had to go half a mile to use the bathroom and
then she has to go home to her kids and tuck
them into bed at night I was like oh man like
to to her kids that she's a Superhero you know
she's like she's doing it she's Paving away for
these children and they have no idea the kind of
stuff she has to deal with at work maybe they have
some sement of understanding because she is you
know a black woman in the world and like these
kids have to experience that because of where they
live and the time they're living in but the fact
that she's experiencing that as well and then she
has to go and put on a brave face for them was
just really uh really inspiring ing you know and I
I liked all the stuff that we got to experience I
the reason why I said earlier because like you you
know that it's two years but I think a lot because
the stuff with mersi and her was like it was in
smaller bits if that whole romance aspect felt a
little fast for me I was like they M and then he's
coming to dinner and then they're getting married
I was like oh damn okay this is like boom boom
boom they had good chemistry don't get me wrong
but I just feel like I would have liked to seen
more of that you know and yeah I it is a little
disheartening to find out that they weren't
actually really good friends in real life and
I think something I would have liked to have seen
addressed is the fact that um octavus Spencer's
character's achievement had an adverse effect on
affecting Catherine and we didn't really touch
on that at all during the movie but you know I
don't it's not directly her fault for going after
something that she wanted to be the supervisor
while she was trying to gain respect within uh the
room yeah of these these crafts she knew that she
that they were going to figure it out so if she
figured it out she could help bring everyone along
with her yeah yeah so that was like the purpose of
it uh yeah know man I I I agree with you I I still
think because of the time it takes place in that
I I weird didn't question if that was true if
she had to like go go to the bathroom um yeah
I'm like you just accept it sounds like a thing
that someone would probably have to endure that
a black woman would probably have to endure in a
workplace like this during this time and and as
much as this is like the PG movie because it's
like a family accessible version of this story
which is why I I give a lot of it to the pass
because it is and gr like I cannot talk from the
black experience of watching a movie like this I
can not talk from the African-American experience
of it I I'm watching from that lens of like it's
a PG movie so I know they're going to like tone
down a lot of like what the day-to-day really felt
like during this time you know so as much as they
dramatize certain aspects to hammer in like
even how in the fact versus fiction page they
were explaining how you know Katherine didn't even
really feel the racism and that's probably because
she I can imagine I'm going to make an assumption
here I I don't really like to make an assumptions
I'm going to I would imagine that when you grow
up in a state like that being a black woman you
probably deal with all kinds of [__] all the
[__] time that this is probably like so minimal
in comparison that's like yeah no it's h it's
here but I'm not that affected by it because I've
dealt I deal with so much worse on a day-to-day
basis you know so I can imagine that that that
is probably it so you do need like the drama for
your specific narrative that you're going to tell
because you otherwise people aren't going to
really if we did the super realistic version
people probably wouldn't show up for the movie um
you know it might not be as interesting enough you
know unless you're like Christopher Nolan making
the film white saving their black story well if it
was a realistic version of the film like none of
this would would correlate because all the stuff
happened at different times so I will judge it as
a narrative and as a narrative I I do think that
uh yeah I I kind of do wish because you start off
with the three women and they do seem like they
really just Splinter off Splinter off and I wish
there was a bit of a stronger connective bow to
them yeah because I together again I would kind of
forget about uh octavus Spencer and Janelle Monae
yeah i' forget about M Jan mon alavia Spencer cuz
I felt like her was like the C or D story of this
whole movie exactly there was yeah was 2 hours and
7 minutes I feel there was a lot going on for that
amount of time cuz they're like yeah there's their
stories and stories of the church the stories of
what's going on in with civil rights and then
there's her getting married you know on top of
that or her relationship and yeah the also the
I guess it was just to establish but I thought
the her being like this young Prodigy in the 20s
up to her adulthood would be more like relevant
yeah because like seeing her seeing her see the
the shapes and geometry I was like I guess that's
just a starting point like an entry point to to
show how long she's been this smart I was like
yeah I think you know maybe her being doubted
everyone okay everyone in the black community
was super supportive of these three women being
like these uh these forward smart you know I'm
sure they said the pay wasn't great but still I I
think that I maybe because the PG movie they don't
want any like additional like layers on top of the
fact that you know they're these black wom within
this uh this world of of NASA and like being the
minority in that part but also push back from
within the community as well that are complicated
things but yeah and it was nice to see you know
support of black husbands or black romantic uh
people in this as you were kind of saying in
the movie A lot of the times these movies will you
know like like's got an alcoholic black husband or
boyfriend or something you know that's something
that's something I will I will say like there
wasn't it was very Hollywood eyes but it wasn't
like the stereotypical movie in which we see where
it's like you know about like drums or like the
baby mama drama or like all of this stuff like
granted was is which is obviously real people's
experiences but I liked that it the light in which
uh these women were painted in in this movie I
love that they had a straight up white saer vot
that makes me so happy like they completely made
that [__] up it's crazy that dude wasn't even
real bro it's probably like one of the biggest
moment of the movie that is such a big moment
happen he's three different guys and right away
you were like that probably didn't happen right
away he said it I'm like yeah it probably didn't
happen he looked it up like this guy didn't even
exist and it's such a big moment in the movie
insane such a crowning achievement look what
I've done oh it's so funny wow that cracks me up
that was a great moment though it was it was good
I like that [__] I do I eat it up eat up eat up
the cliches because well like I think the movie
is is very for a movie that starts off about
like geometry and shapes I what I respect very
much so is the the way this movie is framed I I
think there's the I think the cinematography in
this movie is the kind of thing that could
easily be overlooked but there's there's a
lot of like wide framing that they do throughout
where I felt like every shot was actually really
composed but it wasn't done in a way that was to
like go look at me I'm a cool director you know
but it's still shot really well like every shot is
really well composed but it doesn't feel flashy or
self-indulgent it's a little self-indulgent in the
writing but not so much in the actual directing
they did and even though Kevin CER was a madeup
guy I thought he actually did a really great
job thought Kevin CER was excellent I I I really
liked him a lot um still no B no no no boldness
on the just made him like that the only really
nice white guy all n is Kevin cner all he cares
about science space and equal rights so funny cuz
you're like there's no way you're the only one the
fact you're the only one makes me go there must
have been other people who were cool with black
people or you had or it's totally [__] that you
you were the only one who was nice yeah um as we
were watching it I realized I'm like I don't think
Kristen dun has any other scenes with anybody else
in this movie yeah yeah or to and that's the other
Pitfall of the movie they go into white Redemption
like racist Redemption character mode with with
some of these people you know and um like look
they can change we all can change we should accept
black view that quote Oh that was such a terrible
quote from that director but man that cheese I
love the cheese in the moment I really do I I I
can acknowledge it because it is one of those
things where you're like oh it is the line it
it is the line that uh Octavia Spencer has the
the bar that she drops of of when kirston dun
says I have nothing against you know y'all and
then she goes uh I know you believe that fact
and that's kind of this movie this movie believes
that everything it's doing is great and and that
it's it's well-intentioned it's like they so when
I'm watching this film I'm going well it it's got
heart's in the right place I think they think
their hearts in the right place and that's okay
I guess look at us look let's Pat ourselves in the
back for this one guys the end of the day they're
saying don't be racist that one can't be wrong
with that don't be racist believe in black woman
in science yeah and at theend day did introduce
to a really cool story with and with great
performances from particularly um what's her name
teraji I don't know Taj P Henson that is her name
I don't know why I gu myself the bathroom scene or
the reveal the when she's talking to Kevin CER I'm
like that's your Oscar moment that's your Oscar
scene right there that's what I mean that moment
right there I was I got distracted going this is
totally like Oscar Oscar scene here that's the
scene they play with the Oscars great speech but
totally totally aware what this scene I'm looking
at is right now like really well done but I'm also
hyper aware that this is your Oscar bait scene oh
yeah oh something I wanted to see the um if this
was up for an Oscar the costume you're chargeing
for over time we're about to 20 seconds away from
Two and a Half armor we're going to say that it
was not n for an Oscar oh let's want to see if
it's nominated for anything we can find out yeah
let's find out I don't have the a whole bunch
of other stuff to do after this year let's find
it all right osar let's go let's go what were you
were you nominated for anything what do you look
nominated for three Oscars ah costuming is one
of them I know it I hope so and Kevin CER was
Nom that would be crazy you can see it happening
didn't Sandra b win for the Blind Side did she
yeah think what you w for I've never seen it I
got to watch it especially now I'll watch it by
myself I don't [Laughter] care damn you internet
load okay here we go oh dude it was nominated for
best pitcher was it really I thought it was
good I don't think it was best picture good
OCT oia Spencer got oh best supporting actress
okay yeah so okay no costume ones I mean Octavia
Spencer's like Oscar darling she won for the
help oh such a white saers movie still need to
watch great movie though I love that [Laughter]
movie problematic way more problematic than this
movie really oh yeah when you look up that [__]
freaking um what's her name Viola Davis like says
that like that was a mistake for her to make
that movie yeah really yeah yo so good at it
what he said she shouldn't have made it that's
crazy something something along the lines pretty
much like disowning the film oh wow okay now
that makes me want to watch it more and the
writer best adapted screenplay okay could have
SW was nominated for costuming well well well
got nominated for something so I'm half right
dude dude M Hera won the best actor at the BET
awards are you serious for barely in the movie
showing up and being Pleasant you just he just
nice just a nice black man that's all he whatever
I'm sure there's an actor more deserving that year
oh it's because it's shared with um luk cage
because he had like a multiple amount of roles
that year I think oh okay all right all right
okay that makes more sense right is that this
movie is telling me that was my introduction
name Luke Cage oh my God he's one of the best
wies favorite movies greenbook have you seen that
green book's great I love that movie best wh one
of the [Music] best it's a buddy movie it's a
road trip buddy movie oh my God but it's he's
fantastic in that movie he is he won the Oscar
as he should have as you should have and um and
and U when when the director won best picture
I don't think you even think MERS Le oh wow of
course he didn't of course he didn't white white
thanks for getting me here savior Savor mov best
one oh God we could have had a more nuanced uh
discussion about it but I think we I think we
did our job we we were honest and uh I liked
it what would you give it out of 10 er let's
end this I go to seven I'm probably there with
you yeah seven what's up Rod Tomatoes that's a
great movie though which one American fiction
thanks for watching a movie I know I know
my fourth favorite movie in
[Laughter] 2023 damn dude 93% all the out of
50,000 people wow they they are how many of
them are [Laughter] white oh man all right let's
do a let's do a whole new [Laughter] review oh
God that's crazy it's a true Triumph I'm just
going to type in an important film what if we
like the only ones who like had slight
issues with it I thought it was a good
movie The Wrong lesson white people learn
from White saer movies yeah no man it's a
good movie yeah I all the all the leads were
great you know it's just the the moving around
of times and and creating a story hey it's
a crowd pleasing good time I had a fun time
Aaron does it feel good movie I had a fun time
feel good movie inspired all righty guys well
what do you think about hidden figures leave
your thoughts down below be sure to uh should
I watch The Blind Side should you should watch
The Blind Side watch The Blind Side then talk
about how that movie is problematic nah dude
there's a crowd fer white savior movies are
meant to be crowd fers they are that's what they
all are just enjoy them and don't think about
it they meant to be they're meant to be like
yeah it's meant to ease your white guilt it's
okay oh God I think the intention of
white savior movies too is to inspire
white people to not be racist that's the
Genius of them Aon we're not so bad it's
okay is that look look doesn't it feel good
to not be to not be racist we could be like
that like wow I shouldn't be racist
that's cool it works I think it's a
great movie uh leave your thoughts down
below hidden figures 2 Katherine Ward
turn Maria Hammond Maria it was your birthday
recently so wanted to say happy birthday to
you and for 2024 we got to send you a gift yes
we do what are we realistically going to send
her a puppy no uh your responsibility we don't
want it we found it on the street take it please
take it is it alive we just packed it in a
UPS box taped it like fragile here's a bowl
of water hopefully it doesn't fall over spill
all over this thing um oh goodness we could
get her something commemorative we could name
a star after her that's not a bad gift John you
know I'm saying like I mean of all things to
commemorate your cost more than what she pays
every month for undoubtedly so you know what
we'll have to financial if you can increase
your pledge so we can get you this St this
gift yeah I think you only have to pay for
it once so like you know you don't subscribe to
the star unfair see what you did you wanted the
start and now you just took advantage of
us made it seem like you forging and now
we got to give you a gift once you fully paid
off your gift thanks but seriously app we got
we got to get you of it already thinking about
it but no thank you for being such an amazing
human being here's to another 78 more years
of minim enjoying not saying you're 78 I was
just throwing out a random number just to stay
alive for at least that much more time lives
past like 80 on average right yeah it's like the
going rate right now what is the average person
Maria let's make this really fun for your
birthday what is the average mortality yeah
John type it in what is the average mortality
rate what is the a average I really don't know
how3 okay so we're getting close 7316 years
according to quar okay the average life
expectancy in the world right now hope
I hope you be the first person what is
the oldest person I've ever lived who's
the old actually 70 years for men and
75 for women yeah okay they got less
problems that's why that's right much
more relaxed life what is the oldest person
how old is the current oldest person in the
world oh you can beat them all right Maria they're
only 116 years old they live in Spain their name's
also Maria oh my God holy [__] it was meant to
be Maria you got to be the new dominant extended
life Maria yes if you could just make it to
118 I think you got a good amount of distance
between the next runner up so we're going to
do whatever it takes that's what we're going
to do we're going to send you an IV we're
going to get you cry Frozen we're going to
uh send you some vitamins we're going to get
you some uh oh oh that that baby blood stuff
that people are always freaking out about yeah
people talk about quality of life not quantity
hell with that I don't care how miserable
you get I don't care if you develop some
debilitating disease over the next couple years
and you're just like oh my God just put me out
of my misery no we will trap you we're going
to get you that hydrochrome even if we have to
just keep your head alive in a tank like futur
Rama we will do it to make sure you make it to
that's your gift that's your GI put your head
over here is not letting you die yes your gift
is forced immortality it's good so yeah happy
birthday Maria love you you've been an absolute
gem in our lives and you you know damn well
that we know that so thank you my [Music] dear